okay so that's another issue that I'd
like to bring up because one of the
things I cannot figure out is the
alliance between the post modernists and
the neo-marxists I can't understand the
causal relationship there because that
tell me if you disagree with this okay
because I'm a psychologist not a
sociologist and so I'm dabbling in
things that are outside of my field of
expertise and there is some danger in
that but the center the central post
modernist claim seems to me that because
there's a near infinite number of ways
to interpret a complex set of phenomena
which which actually happens to be the
case that you can't make a case that any
of those modes of interpretation are
canonical and so if they're not
canonical if that and if that canonical
element isn't based in some kind of
reality then it serves some other master
and so the master that it hypothetically
serves for the post modernists is
nothing but power because that seems to
be everything that they believe in they
don't believe in competence they don't
believe in Authority they don't seem to
believe in an objective world because
everything is language mediated so it's
an extraordinarily cynical perspective
that that because there's an infinite
number of interpretations none of them
are canonical you can attribute it
everything to power and dominance okay
so that does that seem like a reasonable
summary of the okay it's a radical
relativism now but the strange thing is
despite okay and so what goes along with
that is the demolition of grand
narratives and so that would be
associated for example with the
rejection of thinkers like Jung and Eric
Norman because of course they're
foundational thinkers in relationship to
the idea that there are embodied grand
narratives that's never touched but then
despite the fact that the grand
narrative is rejected there's a neo
Marxism that's tightly tightly allied
with post-modernism that also seems to
shade into this strange identity
politics and I don't two things I don't
understand the causal relationship there
like the the skeptical part of me thinks
that post-modernism was a was an
intellectual its intellectual camouflage
for the continuation of the kind of
pathological Marxism that produced the
Soviet Union and that has no independent
existence as an intellectual field
whatsoever but I still can't underst
and how the postmodernists can make the
no grand narrative claim but then
immerse themselves in this grand
narrative without anyone pointing out
the evident contradictions like I don't
understand that so what do you think
about that well I can only speak about
literary professors really and they
seemed to me almost universally in the
u.s. to be very naive I they seem to
know nothing about actual history
political science or economics so it is
simply an attitude they have an attitude
Marxism and become simply a badge by
which they Telegraph their their
solidarity with a working class that
they have nothing to do with right I
mean generally nothing but contempt yes
and anything is that the campus leftist
are most notoriously for their for their
rather snobbish treatment of staff and
they don't they don't have any rapport
with the actual working class members of
the you know of the infrastructure the
janitor the janitors and you know and
even even the secretaries there's a kind
of high and mighty aristocracy you know
about their duties just these are people
who who have wandered into the English
department and are products of a time
when during the the new criticism may
wait when history of history and
psychology had been excluded right I
mean my ambition okay was I mean I love
the new criticism okay as a style of
textual analysis right and and that in
the new criticism had multiple
interpretations okay that were possible
okay and then and they were encouraged
in fact one of the one of the great
projects was made in Max of serious 20th
century reviews when you had at least
some books I adored them in college it
was about Jane Austen or about you know
Emily Bronte or about Wordsworth and
they were collections of alternate views
of the same thing the idea that there
were no alternative views and there was
no relativistic in the situational kind
of an interpretive approach
it's nonsense okay about but the point
was we needed to restore history to
literary literary study okay and we
needed to add psychology to it because
it was there was great animus against
Freud when I arrived in graduate school
in fact I actually went into the
director of Graduate Studies and
protested the way Freud in Freudian were
you
as negative terms play in a sneering way
by the very wass professors so we need
to do it actually
it seemed like we were moving there came
in the early 1970s was a great period of
psycho biography about great about
political figures okay so I thought it's
happening let's say and all of a sudden
it all got short-circuited by this
arrival you know of post structuralism
and post-modernism in the in the in the
1970s right so I I feel I'm an old
historicism okay not a newest or so so I
having I think newest or so there's an
absolute scam right and it's like it's
just a way it's like tweezers you like
just you pick a little bit of this a
little bit of that a little bit of that
you make a little tiny salad I guess and
I'm some of this atomized thing really
it's supposed to mean something it's all
can be very superficial very cynical a
very distance I like I am I am the
product okay of old historicism the
German philosopher Strauss of a
professional when I was a child what was
ejected archeology everything I ever
think about or say is is related to an
enormous time scheme okay from from
antiquity and indeed from the Stone Age
and that is the problem with these
people they're they're mal educated the
post modernists and academic Marxist
okay are mal educated embarrassingly so
okay they know nothing before the
present SoCo okay it's absolutely a joke
before the Enlightenment perhaps he
might be useful people to talk about
what happened after neoclassicism which
by the way he failed to notice okay
right a lot of what he was talking about
it turns out to see be simply the
hangover of neoclassicism okay this this
is how ignorant that man was i mean he's
he it was he was not talented as a
researcher he knew absolutely nothing
okay was so you know nothing about
antiquity how can you make any kind of
large structure I'm large mechanism you
know to analyze Western culture without
knowing about classical antiquity